We just saw a simplified
explanation of direct.
Here we see essentially the same thing,
but in the more likely and
more complicated case where Dr.
Johnson and Dr.
Jones are connected to separate HISPs.
Here, S/MIME is used to
encrypt the attachment
containing the patient record.
SMTP is used to send secure email from
an email client like Microsoft Outlook.
HTTP/S is used for
sending web mail, like Google Mail.
The sender's HISP can discover or
find the recipient provider's X.509
certificate, their public key,
using DNS or
LDAP, two technologies for managing
distributed resources over a network.
Once it has the recipient's public key,
the sender's HISP uses it
to encrypt the message.
It them uses SMTP to send the message to
the recipients HISP having used DNS or
LDAP again to find that HISP based
on the recipient's email address.
The recipient's HISP
decrypts the message
using the recipient's private key,
which is normally stored in the HISP as
a service to its registered providers.
The recipient then retrieves
the message like any email, but
using the secure versions of
either Post Office Protocol, POP,
or Internet Message Access Protocol,
IMAP email retrieval.
Which of these could be
a direct attachment?
A fax TIFF file,
scan of a paper document,
a printed version of a chart in
PDF format, or all of the above?